c'est vrai que je sais que tous les deux
c'est c'est une longue histoire
non mais encore une fois moi je reviens
je reviens un texto parce
qu'effectivement en tapant sur la salis
bon après midi visio il va sur les
réseaux et dieye maïs et il s'est excusé
bon très bien j'ai bien compris que vous
étiez content d'être ici que ça vous
fait une grosse pub et que vous avez
découvert avec joie n'est le fait d'être
célèbre pouvoir twitté toute la soirée
tu sais ces cas-là on comptait
accueillir non mais je voulais je dis
non non on va se mettre d'accord tout de
suite aux éau va se mettre d'accord
d'accord mais pas fait cinq ans en
décembre en alerte ou non attendez je
viens de voir mon jeune rambouillet je
fais 50 bornes
alors si vous pensez que je viens ici
pour ma gloire je me tire ben voyons ça
il a raison je suis d'accord avec toi
papier joie parce qu'on peut penser que
je m'attendais à ce que j'attendais
faites pas vous faites appliquons boon
est enfin mr moi je veux dire à un
moment donné soyons restons sérieux j'ai
deux problèmes avec vous soit vous
m'écoutez rien soit vous ne comprenez
rien jusqu'à tout à l'heure en coulisses
je disais à vos assistants que je
pensais que vous n'écoutez rien tout à
coup je commence à en douter la manière
dont vous maquiller ce soir je commence
à en douter
je vous rappelle monsieur que ici
effectivement je suis un habitait alors
que vous êtes chez vous c'est vrai et
que la façon dont hier soir vous m'avez
traité
et bien si vous considérez qu'il n'y a
pas de problème eh ben c'est nous
n'avons rien à faire moi je suis venu
parce qu'on m'a invité et parce qu'un
tableau va être projeté qui montrent
effectivement un élément style date en
ciel et qu'on vous raconte n'importe
quoi dans cette émission et que personne
ne vérifie
je suis le seul à vérifier mais on a
compris on est tous des bills vous avez
là vous avez d'absence elle ne veut pas
vous avez la sensation
vous n'êtes pas moins un personnage
extrêmement dangereux je vous le dis
droit dans les yeux vous êtes un mec
extrêmement dangereux pourquoi j'avais
pris le parti pris de venir à l'encontre
de tout ce qui se fait mais vous dites
qui vous paraissent ps vous dites il
vous permettra il faut pas [ __ ] la
trouille aux gens je pense qu'ils
avaient effectivement vous avez dit hier
quand on vous avait dit oui le variant
brésilien on ne sait pas si les plus
dangereuses ou alors c'est quoi tes
rires mais c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça
mais je vous demande qu'est ce que c'est
comment tu es moi c'est quoi ça sert
lisa sion ça c'est les sources du
ministère de la santé brésilienne si on
tombé cette nuit d'accord intéressant à
regarder
ah oui d'accord quoi mais ce à quoi
expliquer moi je veux expliqué fabrice
di vizio c'est que le variant brésilien
d'après ces chiffres n'apportent n'amène
pas plus de décès à l'eau plus
d'hospitalisations chez les plus jeunes
c'est ça regardez j'ai bien compris le
regarder les chiffres
j'ai bien compris voilà voilà donc c'est
ce qu'il sait ce qu'il dit il dit qu'en
fait don qui hier ont parlé du var y en
a un qui m'a très bien dangereux chez
les jeunes c'est ce qui se dit puis donc
auront dernière plus de il ya plus de
jeunes apparemment en réanimation non
non c'est la preuve que non la preuve
que non puisque les chiffres pieds dans
la boue par les dangereux tout à l'heure
j'ai mis ce qui est dangereux c'est ce
qui est en jeu c'est martin blachier qui
est dangereux ou cette fois c'est
dangereux parce qu'on va rien lâcher je
n'ai entendu vous dire je ne m'avoue
champion brésilien que ouais touché plus
de jeunes
c'est ce qui m'a dit en coulisse à moi
ouais tu y croies ovarien voisine bien
toi puis bah non il ya des chiffres une
dizaine en moi j'y crois pas aux
parisiens
non ça c'est qu'on a dit ça nous
apprenons cernon anglais il a dit je ne
sais pas il avait je ne sais pas combien
n'est pas dire aujourd'hui effectivement
ces vaillants brésilien était besoin
qu'il a dit sur ce bateau donc c'est
vrai qu'il écoute est rien exact comme
d'hab qu'apparemment y avait des
patients plus jeunes en réanimation
on sait pas si c'est parce que les
jeunes machin les jeunes chose alors
qu'il ya pas de patients plus jeunes en
réanimation
on vous a fait le même coup que les
variants anglais on vous a dit sur bfm
un professeur de 20 janvier était plus
contagieux et est plus contagieux mais
pas plus mortelle aboyer sur n'est pas
plus dangereux les chiffres anglais le
montrer à l'époque et le variant
brésilien est plus contagieuse s'il est
peut-être plus contagieux mais il n'a
pas d'incidence à ce stade à ses abonnés
a peut-être mais ce que je veux dire ce
qu ils dangereux monsieur castaldi sur
un point ce que vous ne semblez pas
comprendre c'est que aujourd'hui j'avais
une conversation téléphonique
le spécialiste du aujourd'hui c'est à
mon tour de le faire c'est me dit me
mohamed à mon tour j'ai eu un coup de
fil aujourd'hui deux psychiatres qui
sont clients avec des défénestration de
gamin de 11 ans elle ne s'est jamais vu
le service de pédo psychiatrique pas
très loin de chez moi de dreux est plein
à craquer parce que les gens n'en
peuvent plus ils ont peur ils ont peur
et vous ne pouvez pas venir
effectivement continuer à distiller la
peur de la sorte
et si vous considérez que effectivement
en
m'appuyant sur les données de la science
je suis dangereux le seul qui l'ait
monsieur castaldi c'est celui qui parle
sans savoir ce sont vos invités qui
parlent sans savoir quand jimmy mohamed
vient chez vous pour dire je suis
favorable à l'avancé fantaisie pas de la
marque et à qui les gens qui n'est pas
la bonne solution pas on n'est pas là
pour attaquer qui que ce soit c'est un
très bon médecin le problème qu'il pose
pas en ces termes
williams et moi ils considèrent comme
une provocation le fait que je lui
demande ses sources
mais quel est donc ce pays où quand on
demande les sources à quelqu'un sur ce
qu'il dit ça constitue une provocation
le débat ne se nourrit-il pas
précisément des sources que vous
réclamez une mesure aussi radicale
est ce que ça ne nécessite pas comme un
minimum ses sources ce qui vous a
convaincu un mois y compris n'a jamais
je voulais pas ce qu'est ce que vous
savez sur les divisions je trouve que
son système de 2,2 de débat c'est qu'on
lui pose une question il répond qu une
autre question systématiquement on dit
reconnaître
moi je ne suis pas moi je ne suis pas
médecin moi je vis dans un monde
monsieur division lui dans un monde ou
alors si vous avez raison de dire que
tous les jours dans le monde entier les
gens qui nous parlent nous montrer 10 d
énorme connerie je ne peux pas ce jeu ne
donnerait accès je ne peux pas accepter
alors soit dégagée laberdesque jeu
réagir m division le problème avec vous
c'est que vous parlez toujours des
sources des autres voilà il vous je
connais par coeur votre système c'est à
dire que vous cherchez toute la nuit des
heures entières et vous bossez mais non
la source
le chiffre qui va vous donner raison
mais on mais oui mais oui mais vous ne
vous assénez ça depuis des mois mais
vous savez regarder mais vous nous avez
parlé des masques pendant des mois très
difficiles
les masses qui sont utiles fabrice mais
alors c'est une question intéressante la
question des masques rappelez moi
monsieur verdez oui quitte à l'origine
de l'obligation du port du masque à
l'intérieur mettre une vision m division
m division mais il est la radio c'est
bon il a fait un recours quand on est à
tergiverser accroître giron ça qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a dit on peut pas
tergiverser jeu parce que le masque à
l'intérieur offre une certaine
protection dont on ignore la nature
exacte encore encore une fois vous
n'écoutez pas ça va commencer trois
raisons les dumas je vous parlais sans
doute avec henin
parce qu'à l'intérieur je vous parlais
la du masque à l'extérieur nous avait
dit que ce n'était pas utile oui je vous
avais dit où sont vos sources mais moi
j'ai passé la nuit aussi comme vous et
là j'ai des sources le dernier
fusion l'obligation du masque à
l'extérieur donc six ans martin blachier
qu'il voulait dire antoine flahault
monsieur est alors en émoi mais a
expliqué me source allez-y c'est
intéressant je vous remercie de
d'apporter vos souris ça va partir en
semoule avril 2020 selon des
scientifiques messieurs lions gate il
compare donc je me suis dit 2000 21
avril 2020 c'est l'ultime vous savez
mais alors ça c'est la raison qui la
verrait la wii avril 2001 monsieur je
vous parle d'une étude qui vient ça
voulait à la convention signer même la
cdg la conclusion alors la conclusion
cette étude apporte un élément de preuve
supplémentaire du rôle protecteur des
masques les masques quand un effet
protecteur significatif contre le risque
de contracter une infection respiratoire
virales
on parle bien entendu de masques à
l'extérieur donc vous voyez moi j'ai une
chance qu'il il inverse ne vous riez pas
c'est que même fonctionnaire bouladier
mais c'est intéressant dit est
intéressant parce que vous voyez bien
que on est au coeur du débat on est en
avril 2020 en avril 2001 le virus est
arrivé en europe ya un mois qu'est ce
qu'on fait on applique un principe de
précaution
l'épreuve on les a pas on a
effectivement des éléments et parce
c'est exactement comme ça que ça
fonctionne une épidémie
sauf que depuis et bien des fins de les
chercheurs ont travaillé les
scientifiques ont travaillé
pourquoi ne prenez pas la recommandation
de juillet 2021 de juillet 2020 parlons
du haut comité de santé publique pas ça
vous prenez pas il source postérieur je
vais vous dire pourquoi vous les prenez
pas parce que vous ne connaissez pas et
un gilles verdez 10 qui m'interpelle au
plus haut point il dit je viens ici en
révisant mais monsieur je crois que vous
n'avez pas compris
en fait que c'est ma spécialité vous
n'êtes pas compris que j'ai une équipe
on a derrière sans sel ou alors une
équipe non mais on est dix dans ce
carnet et vous n'avez pas compris que
j'ai à mon cabinet un staff de meilleur
mais des meilleurs médecins est le seul
à savoir où on est rien
évidemment je regrette je regrette c'est
d'avoir fait ça qu'il était absolument
pas un geste de violence et de
d'énervement et je vous le dis vous êtes
absolument en débat un supporte à vous
couper la parole vous laissez pas parler
monsieur vous êtes suffisamment larges
ce soir il est cool il vous est
suffisant vous êtes vous êtes très sûr
de vous des tricks utilisé très brillant
laissez moi finir il coupé coupé coupé
groupe est bel et bien voilà la
logorrhée la chasse verbale c'est ça je
sais comment monsieur je veux dire vous
avez trois mots de vocabulaire
supplémentaires mais oui mais c'est bon
mais c'est moi j'étais je savais ce que
vous aimez j'étais à l'école j'étais à
l'école caution jugée bien connu des
gens très brillants les grands
intellectuels il était chez moi à ma
table à la campagne chez mes
grands-parents bavard donc les jambes
pour l'intelligence et avec l'eau de
tous écrit vais donc c'est bon alors qu
elle qu'il faut c'est bon non
excusez-moi mais des plis qui nous et il
est temps suffisant comptable
prétentieux suffisant et un support
quand même aller ce message intéressant
ça c'est intéressant que je suis
prétentieux monsieur je ne sais pas si
je suis prête à la ceiba baril vaut
peut-être peut-être un peut-être j'ai
pas la prétention de ne pas l'être mais
peut-être effectivement que j'ai une
qualité monsieur par rapport à vous oui
je sais de quoi je parle
oui mais pas génial bravo monsieur aller
au gouvernement en clair la paix en
macro prenant la place de l'hérault est
génial vous êtes génial je vous êtes
génial bravo le gouvernement a beau mais
[Rires]
laissez moi aussi j'étais très tout ça
vous amuse sur environ c est ce que vous
vous rendez compte monsieur que de
l'image que vous renvoyez aux français
il sait qu'il images raw france est
exactement quelqu'un images on vous
parlait en fait au moins gilbert
vieillissement on peut débattre et
discuter un tremblement de vous merci
[Rires]
je connaissais pas les parce que vous
vous croyez drôle jettera j'essayais je
sais effectivement de vous expliquer une
chose importante à mes yeux c'est que
quand vous arrivez avec des sources au
moins vous faites semblant de savoir
c'est pas mal déjà au moins c'est bien
beau mais d'une adhésion à l'otan
j'ai hésité mais aussi des mouches sur
ce point c'est que j'ai hésité à chaque
fois que je venais baba faire désolé ça
brille à faire quelque chose que j'ai
pas fait et je ne sais quoi à chaque
fois de venir avec autant de copies
d'exemplaires des sources que j'avais à
pour les distribuer à thonac distraire à
l'école une grève en me disant peut-être
que certains d'entre nous fait coûteront
moins con ce soir et alors c'est bien
beau d'être connaît alors super mais non
mais non
si oui à 50 des revenus à 48%